yes okay so yep for the presentation
today first I'm going to do a dash
introduction and then I'm going to go
over some sample applications so we can
see what's possible and then if we have
time I'll just do a super simple demo so
you guys can check out the the code and
the structure used to create the dash
applications so I'm going to start with
a quick overview of plotly so dash is a
new are relatively new we released it
about a year and a half ago so it's a
relatively new project from plotly so at
plotly we have a lot of moving parts
going on so first we have plotly j/s
which is our open sourced
Jayesh charting library and this is
built on top of d3 and stack GL and then
we have some api's for common data
science languages so you guys may have
seen John Mises talk earlier about our
Python API and we also have our MATLAB
Julia yep so then we have a chart studio
which is our online platform and this
also includes a graphical user interface
so if you don't quite program or you
work with colleagues that don't program
this is a good a good tool to get up and
running with the same visualizations
that you can create in Python or
JavaScript and then finally we have -
which is what I'll be focusing on today
and this is our framework for building
web applications and this is going to be
in pure Python so just to get started
and if you guys aren't familiar with
plotly they're interactive
visualizations so you can click on the
legend to remove things click and drag
to zoom and we also have hover
information there so these are just some
of my favorite charts so we can just see
also annotations if you want to
create a periodic table and animations
as well yep so yep so that's just a
little taste of some of the
visualizations that we're we're creating
so now to get into the main topic of -
so what is - you're looking at it I've
done this presentation as a - app and so
yep basically like I mentioned it's just
our productive framework for building
web applications in Python so we created
this so that people that are doing their
data analysis in Python can just take it
all the way and get their presentation
and web application and everything up
and running in that language that
they're comfortable with so again it's
particularly suited for anyone working
in Python and we built this on top of
plotly js4 the graphing and then flask
and react GIS so the components are
basically wrappers around a lot of react
components yep so the goal was to just
abstract away the protocols that are
typically required to build interactive
web applications and create a simple
framework for users to code their
applications and so these apps are
rendered in the web browser as you can
see and you can deploy your apps to
servers and then share them via URLs and
then since they're running the browser
it's inherently cross-platform and then
it works on mobile as well and so to get
started with - I've just embedded our
our - documentation in my presentation
here so
URL for that is a plot li / - or - plot
ly will redirect and that's a - app as
well and in an open-source repo so if
you like anything particularly about the
styling of the documentation you can
check out the repo and see how to apply
that to your own application and so I
just want to quickly look at the
installation part so you can check out
how to get started that way so you'll
basically just install the - packages
with pip so you'll install - - HTML
components - core components and then we
just released our - data table which I'm
going to talk about a bit later and so
that's in our lead part here of our
install documentation as well so in the
documentation when we make an update we
update the documentation so you have the
latest version of the packages available
to check out there great so I'm going to
just move on so we can check out kind of
how to structure the application code
and then look at interactivity and
controls in the application so first
you'll start by creating a Python file
and in that file you'll define your
layout so here we're just defining app
dot layout and then in that layout I'll
have my main HTML div there so I'm just
using HTML Duck t'v and then as the
children of that I want to add a
drop-down and then a second div which
I'm going to use as a container so when
I make a selection in the drop down the
containers children can get updated so
then for the interactivity will use a
actually can you guys see that on me so
for the interactivity we'll use a call
back so
I'll have my app call back decorator and
then in that it will take an output and
so right now you can only have one
output per callback and then it can take
an array of inputs because you can have
multiple inputs per callback so as the
output I'm using like I mentioned before
the containers so I use the ID of what I
want to update and then the element that
I want to update so I want to update my
output container div and I want to
update the children of that so now for
my input I want to use the drop down as
my input and my drop down ID my drop
down and then I want to use the value
from that so I'm passing value through
my function here and then I just want to
return a string where I'm formatting the
the value returned from the drop down
so here when I make a selection it will
then display my value and the children
of that that div there so like I
mentioned before we can use multiple
inputs in a callback and so in this
example I'm actually first going to
update an input with the first input so
here I'm using American Canada and when
I make the selection of which country
the city radio buttons will update and
then when I make my selection here as
well the final dip here will update
appropriately so if we take a look there
and now we'll see in my final callback
here the array includes both the
countries drop-down and the city
strap-down values for my input array
so a lot of times in applications you'll
especially data visualization in
applications you'll want graph gel down
so when you make a selection in one
graph it will update the next so this is
a super simple example but it's actually
my favorite - example so you can see
this in our interactive graphing section
of the documentation and I really like
this example because it just lays out
how to get that information from the
graph interactivity back so you can then
format that and use that to create your
callbacks so I'm just going to when I
interact with the graph here below the
hovered data click data or zoom and
relay out data
I'll just display what's actually
returned from from plotly jazz in that
in these tips here so we can see how to
zoom out of it when I hover on points we
can see down there that the points array
is updating and I'm getting two points
back because I have my compare hover on
but if I want to move over to closest
when I hover now I'll only get that one
point returned and so we're returning
the curve number which is like which
trace and then also point number index
and then the x and y values as well if
you have applied any custom data or text
to that to that trace when you create
your graph and then click data is
returned in the same format zoom and
layout when you zoom on the graph or
zoom back out which you can do by double
clicking that will update so and then I
don't have it in this example but we
also have selections so we do a box and
a lasso selection which I'll demonstrate
a bit later but we return that data as
well and if you check out the
documentation page the selections
included there
okay so um one of the big things about -
which distinguishes it a bit from a lot
of the plot lead PI work that we saw
earlier where you can have those those
kind of callbacks structures as well is
here we allow a lot of the HTML and CSS
styling to be done so you can design
your layout and CSS as well now if
you're anything like me who works a lot
in Python you may hate CSS with a
driving driving fashion I just it's not
for me
so I typically use in my apps are a
super simple CSS stylesheet that we host
on code pen and that's all throughout
our documentation so you can just grab
that and apply it to your your apps and
you get a basic CSS structure where you
can then create rows and columns and get
a bit more styling here so if we scroll
down we can kind of see how we style
typography headers and then the buttons
as well yep so if you love pain and want
to write your own CSS you can put that
inline or you can use CSS files in your
application folder as well and yep this
is just kind of an example of how your
CSS efforts can pay off so here I have a
little application embedded that's kind
of in a report design and so these
different tabs will display different
sections of the report
but yeah I'll just emphasize that in
addition in addition to the Python there
was some CSS efforts that went into that
application one of the things that I'm
working on now so I think that maybe I
didn't mention before but that's far
everything I've discussed all the
packages and all of the - stuff that
I've discussed has been it's all open
source so we do have a few closed source
editions and so one thing that we're
working on now is a design kit so it's
kind of we're building a GUI for styling
your - applications but I'm not gonna
demo that or get into it today because
it's not part of our open source efforts
but I just want to mention it on this
page because of a bad talk - CSS so much
we're trying to make us try to make a
solution to avoid some of those issues
and even if no one uses it I don't care
because I use it every day so great so
I'm kind of wrapping up with my slides
here so I'll just um just do my ending
before the actual end and I just want to
kind of go over a few and like get in
touch opportunities so I'm going to host
this application so I'll provide the
link to PI data if you want to grab it
that way and also tweet it out via plot
latest Twitter by some other methods we
have our documentation and github so
that's just the main - library but then
we also have repos for - core components
such HTML components those are all
listed here and like I said all those
are open source so contributions are
super welcome we also have a forum
that's extremely act
did so you can get that get that if you
go to our main forum is community ly and
then flash see / - gets you to the -
specific options there and then also if
you have any questions about my
presentation feel free to email me at
Chelsea applause oh oh I I'm too shy for
my personal Twitter so you can feel free
to email me okay so I'm gonna move into
the second part of my talk which is
going to be some example applications
mmm so um like I said this presentation
was done in - our Docs were done in - we
have a gallery in the docs which is a
big list of a lot of examples we made if
you check out the gallery um let me see
if I can get that open for you guys we
have links to not only the hosted
applications so you can see the
application but also a link to a github
repo where all of the code is so um yep
we really recommend if you see something
you like forking the repo and then you
can just edit that and apply your own
own data or just dig into the code to
get a good understanding of how that's
done so yeah so we have like different
examples so if you click on the title it
will open the application or you can
click on the source code so I've opened
up some of my favorite examples and then
I'll do I don't think I did the live
update one so the - data table and so
this is something I mentioned earlier if
you if anyone's familiar with - you
might know that for a really long time
over a year we had the - table
experiment repo going on and just two
weeks ago we released our actual version
of the - data table so that was a really
big effort it involves some typescript
and it just we're really happy that it's
a
extremely feature intensive and it's
working now so yep you can do selections
remove rows remove columns sorting and
filtering as well so we'll see some
sorting those can then update the graphs
you can also edit so you can kind of use
this as a data table that then applies
to the graph so you might notice this is
the Gapminder data set that i've loaded
to create the table but you can create a
table and then fill it out or edit it if
you want to do a live application there
and then if you check out our
documentation on this you'll notice that
we're not super happy it was our
filtering syntax but that's something
that we're going to change pretty soon
so this is in an alpha version and while
stable the filtering syntax is
definitely subject to change so here if
I kind of want to filter I have to do
equals a string and then get that
filtered there it also allows for paging
as well so in this application you can
just also do your filtering do your
sorting and then download the CSV to get
that data okay so this is one an
application that was created by one of
our community members so I'll just
quickly go through it it's pretty
interesting they're just kind of
plotting climate change over different
kind of life spans so you could kind of
look at your lineage and see how climate
change affects different different
people that way so basically if you make
your selections here it will move around
the annotations on the plot so you can
kind of
yep design it for just your own life
event there okay so here we have an
image processing application so what one
of our extremely impressive interns
who's studying image processing made
this and I'm so happy that he did so we
can do a super-cute demo with ponies
wearing sweaters so here here we can
kind of you can upload your own image
and then we're plotting the RGB values
down there you can also do some image
processing on the image so for example
if I really want to focus on the ponies
I can make a selection of not the ponies
and then a blur that out I believe yep
sorry let me undo that yep
so I'm going to make my selection blur
run the operation so you can notice that
this parts a bit blurred now and we can
see how that changed the RGB levels of
that image so what this app is doing I
believe he was using pillow for this but
he's uploading an image and plotting it
on a plot league grid there and then
running the analysis that way and the
updates of this chart then update the
analysis displayed on our histogram here
okay yep so I mentioned earlier that in
addition to the click in hover we also
offer the selection option so here we
can look at different years of poison
and youth poison induced death rates so
it's a bit grim so I'll go through
quickly just to show the selection
making a selection on the chart will
then display the bars that are age
adjusted there and then we can also
select different analyses there which
will then update that bar chart as well
so we can double click to unselect maybe
change the year and then select a
different region yep great so yep and
then finally and this is just a quick
example of doing I'm using an interval
for a live updates so yep so you can see
on about every second we're getting
updates here and then the first two
graphs are plotted by default but if we
want to maybe remove this USD one we can
then add the the next one there or add
it back in so it can add multiple charts
and finally if we want to get the the
pound two dollar can grab that one into
yep so again just want to quickly
demonstrate this as one of the live
update options okay so got through that
so now we have a bit of time to look at
some of the code so I'm gonna go through
and do a super simple application
because a I don't really like live
coding and things be the goal is just so
you guys can see the see the syntax and
gain confidence that anyone in this room
could quickly make a dash application so
first all open up
my app so to prepare I've created a
folder and in that folder I have the
trusty Gapminder CSV and then a skeleton
map here and then in case I forget
everything I've also written out my demo
application to reference great so I can
I'll have to stop other application
great so now if I open up my localhost
will see there is nothing there because
there is nothing in my application yet
okay so I'll explain the parts that I
started out with first so first I have
my imports so in addition to - - core
components and - - HTML components I'm
going to use pandas to read in my csv
and then filter that csv as well i'm
using the external stylesheet because i
don't write any CSS right now and yep so
now we're getting on to the -
application part so here I'm
initializing the app and then I'm going
to read that CSV file and then I'm going
to filter by continent so I'm just
starting out by getting a list of the
continents that are in in that continent
column there so now like we saw before
typically we'll start the - application
by you need to initialize the layout so
you do app dot lay it and then you have
the main HTML div which I'm going to
fill out with the children here so I'm
going to add a header a drop down in the
negraph
and then I'll do a simple call back as
well okay so for the header yep oh sure
sorry
let's see how is that that that should
be pretty good
okay okay so we have I'll just put a
header here and I just want my header to
say hello - and so I'm really excited
because just recently like I think about
within the last month we've added a hot
reloading so now when I save my file
since I have my debug equals true on
down here it will hot reload so I save
and the browser updates so sorry when I
was describing the skeleton before I
forgot to mention I will set the run
server as well and then yep
you can set debug equals true if you
want to get that a hot reloading option
on okay so I have hello - so now I want
to add a drop-down so this was HTML
because the header component is in our
HTML components now I'm going to use
drop down which is our in our - core
components so I'll do DCC drop down and
here I'll set an ID and then I'll set
some options and a value as well so
we'll start for my options so I'm going
to make a drop down of the continents
and I'll set my value to Americas to
start off with so for the options we
have value
and label so for these I'm going to set
it to country so that should be 4c oh
sorry
continents so let's see if I got that
syntax right okay so our drop downs
there so now for the graph I'm just
going to add our graph in there so this
is going to be another dash core
component and I want my graph to be
based on the drop down so in my layout
section here I'm just going to add the
ID and I don't need anything else
because I'm going to define my figure
down in my callback okay so let me
uncomment my cobwebs and I call back
structure here okay so like we saw
before I have my callback decorator and
so now for my dash dot dependencies dot
output I'll include the idea of what I
want to output which is grass and then
all I want to update the figure of the
graph of my graph ID there and then for
my input I want to use the drop-down so
I think I'd call that DD and I want to
use the value okay so now I'm just going
to write a function to do whatever I
want it to do which is going to be
update the graph so here I'm going to
pass in my input value so this function
is going to take the value and on the
value I want to filter my data frame so
a GD f equals D F of continents when
that equals my value I think that needs
to be equals equals okay and now I'll
set my figure
so in the interest of time I'm going to
copy my figure from what I wrote before
whoops
okay and I think I didn't quite get that
right oh yeah sorry you know but she
should be fine for this one yeah okay
and then okay so sorry about that so
I've copied my figure now so to go
through the figure structure that's
going to take data and layout data can
be an array because you can add multiple
traces there but in this case we'll only
have the one and then layouts a
dictionary here where I'm then I'm
setting up the margins just to be a
little more up appropriate and so in my
dad I'm going to set X and y values
based on my filtered data frame here so
I want to use country as X the GDP per
capita is y and then finally I'll size
by life expectancy and then I want to
return the figure and so here we can see
our super simple app and when I make my
selections here that will update and
everything in here is resizable by
default but you can set that up to not
be to be static or we can set our width
to be a percent so for example if I want
to Center my title here
I can add the CSS properties in line in
the style dictionary or here we could
wrap this in a div and then I said that
a div with to be we can just do it so so
now the drop down is the children of the
div and I can set a style here
maybe sometime
and so now we're a little more a little
more styled and looking a little more
ready okay great so I just wanted to
give a quick example of what the the
code looks like there so you can can see
that and feel like you're ready to get
get up and running if you if you choose
and yep I think we have some time for
questions now Thanks
um yep so the question it's more on how
to structure and organize the code right
and so yep for the documentation
purposes you're totally right we usually
put everything in one file and that's so
people can copy and paste but if you
take a look at some of the more intense
examples you'll notice that we are we do
kind of take the approach that you
mentioned where you can put figures in
one file and then call that or basically
put any yeah anything in different files
and so yep if you take a look at some of
the longer applications you'll notice
that we typically do break things into
multiple files and then import from the
different Python files so my
applications that I work on will
typically have like five to ten Python
files and I'll write out like reusable
components so for example like I
mentioned that styling is a pain point
so when I get a header that is centered
that I like I just make that into a
header component and then import that
header dot PI file in all of my
functions and just replace the the title
and reuse that does that answer it
answer the question yep yep no problem
yep
yep yeah you can import what you like we
typically don't like yeah we pretty much
only have examples with graphing of
using plotly because that allows you to
get the graph in the callback using that
DCC graph it would not probably not work
straightforward for you right out of the
box using maybe yeah because I don't you
need to have the interactivity to get
that to work in the callbacks sorry the
question was about using other graphing
libraries and conjuncture with with - so
you can import it in your Python file
and and graph it but to get to use it in
the callback you'll needs you actually
be using the potli library I'm straight
out of the box there yep yep so um what
we've done is we don't have a simple
template but rather this is the case
where instead of creating like simple
templates and putting all of those up we
have kind of templated out a lot of the
examples so like I mentioned all the
codes like for all of our examples are
on github so when we kind of recommend
if you find a layout that you like there
you fork that and then edit based on
based on that in the documentation we
also have if you're using that a CSS
stylesheet that we offer you can use
rows and columns and they're kind of
like the bootstrap method so you can set
up your your define your columns based
on a 1212 column grid
and yep yeah that's a great question so
the questions about deploying an app and
handling multiple user sessions and I'm
so glad you asked that because that was
kind of the whole point of - is yeah
many people can be using the application
at once and it's all independent across
users so I could open this application
you can opener you can open it we can
all open it and play around with it and
you've got a parallel experience there
Thanks yep yep so typically yes you
might have noticed a lot of the examples
I showed were deployed on Heroku and we
have instructions on deploying on Heroku
as well online and yep otherwise yep you
can use philosophy and deploy like if
you want to edit and deploy on open
shift or anything like that that's
possible and then for enterprise use we
also offer a server you can deploy on
but that's that's not part of the open
source package great any other questions
nope cool well if anyone has any
questions definitely let me know or is
that me anymore Thanks
[Applause]